foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh you good dig yes all right guys
Welcome to seldovia Alaska here Mark and
his son Everett are they're hosting us
and we are going to do a whole bunch of
coastal forging and fishing and and
we're gonna try to sample all that the
sea has to offer and Mark here's got his
own YouTube channel the Alaska boys I'll
go ahead and put a link down in the
video description below all right here
hop on in buddy
very important
oh so you were like this is kind of
downtown soldovia it's beautiful little
town and you can see the tide is way out
we didn't just stop for the scenery
good to go now
we're um
there you go okay look what we got on
our way over here that crab yes
you could eat this if you wanted I've
eaten a bunch of these over the years
Jacob do you have your survival shark
with you yes show me there we go
survival shark yeah
okay man we couldn't ask for a more
beautiful day look at this weather
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean we could go out all right guys
you see a little bit of kelp we're gonna
go ahead and grab some and try to make
some spicy pickled kelp
oh yeah look at that
big chunk of bull cow big edible piece
of seaweed gets like 60 feet long just
grab the tip of it there
foreign
there we go
got a nice little jig there
yeah current's moving it is like a river
is it yeah it's a moving contrary too
all right guys we've been jigging a
little bit for a rockfish not much has
happened so we're gonna go out about a
mile and try for some halibut
Ed
the current is ripping we're about 140
feet of water and I've got 350 feet of
line out to hit the bottom
little little sculping
I'm eating them you need one about five
times that big yeah the whole head
holy
these guys have spines right here and
here are the Gill plates and they just
covered in spines
oh what'd you go Mark well I got a small
Irish well uh sculpin an Irish Lord
mine's smaller than yours oh that is
it's a beauty well we're not getting
much other than sculpting here in this
spot so we're gonna pick up and try
another spot
[Applause]
oh you got something going on yeah Leo
flounder nice
you're looking at some fish tacos it
already looks like a tortilla we're
gonna put this in the Fish Box hey there
we go not skunked yeah yeah there you go
that's gone
there we go
there we go flounder are not a popular
fish around here partly because their
meat doesn't keep very well but you know
they're not bad if you eat them fresh
this one's a little little one but that
might even be below our standard we'll
let him go
are you okay yeah sure
this one is bigger
fish
Lift It Up Lift It Up oh yeah it's a
tank oh this is a huge one oh
it works all other flounders I think
that is as much flounder meat as
anyone's gonna want it's a lovely day
but that water is cold my fingers are
frozen pooper
that's all you caught
oh this is quite the playground you guys
got here look at this I started with
this like rope Bridge there started with
this rope bridge and then it kind of
Grew From there almost all this is made
from Salvage stuff
oh look at that Jake what do you think
is that cool
oh I'm really scared on that ball wow
[Music]
oh
your life jacket
yeah
it's a two it's a two person so two
people can poo at the same time
got ourselves a nice big piece of Bowl
kelp here but you can see it's got
little Barnacles and a set of nasty
stuff on the outside so uh we're gonna
just do like you do a potato or carrot
I'm gonna peel it off
quick
we got enough for uh six
yeah
you just kind of bye
there we go got little kelp rings
and you can eat them just like that but
they're quite salty but we're gonna go
ahead and pickle these and I have some
pickle recipes
but you really need to adjust the salt
on them because these things are already
just a little bit too salty I don't
think we should be adding any extra salt
to this
yep
put some dill weed some mustard powder a
couple dried chilies and one of them I
put a habanero in here so we're gonna
have some spicy pickled kelp and I'm
filling up the jars one quarter full
with vinegar
a little bit of white sugar and then
water
did you shake that jar just mix it all
up shake shake shake Senora shake your
body liner yeah that looks pretty good
foreign
[Music]
these flounders have a lot of seaweed in
their belly just like channel catfish
well there is a pile of the teeniest
cutest little fillets
all right we got a whole bunch of
flounder meat we're gonna make some fish
tacos
is
I don't care I'm done with my math
anyway
okay we got some Louisiana fish fry
[Music]
ing
[Music]
life it's the kind of thing wherever
here we go guys okay so we got a little
cilantro lime salsa peppers
cilantro jalapeno sauce There we go
hey in case you're counting it not bad
not bad no it's great
all right guys what'd you think of the
fish tacos
I like the sauce with that you like the
sauce yeah that's good sauce yeah is it
better or grosser than you thought a
little better better
better foreign
oh Jake's just playing in the sand being
a good old boy I got dinner out of the
way finished cleaning up now we're gonna
finish cooking these kelp pickles
[Music]
there we go six jars of kelp pickles
we'll see how that tastes tomorrow
alrighty it's bedtime so I've got to go
ahead and get everything ready get
Jacob's clothes laid out because he is
all wet
okay
it's gonna be pretty cold tonight it's
supposed to be down in the low 20s
was about an hour and a half before the
evening low tide we got some more food
exposed
check this out
it's one of my favorite edible plants
the ends of this seaweed is it inflated
like little balloons
um they taste like salty Garden peas
just really nice not too salty just
really delicious Raw
and as you can see there's a lot of it
oh
some pretty good clams around if the sea
otters don't get to them first
well tomorrow morning we're supposed to
have a pretty extreme low tide and so a
lot more Beach is going to get exposed
we're gonna get a chance to do foraging
for octopus crabs clams maybe scallops a
whole bunch of things are going to get
exposed and I'm looking forward to
trying it out and catching and cooking
all sorts of different things but it's
getting late I gotta get Jacob to bed so
I better get heading back Daddy
[Music]
what
if
you've got sleeping bags see
is that nice and warm
it's late it's way past Jacob's bad time
so we're gonna go to bed I'll see you
guys in the morning
thank you sleep good
[Music]
oh good morning look at this
oh that's gorgeous
oh it's nice and warm in here what
what we're about three and a half hours
before low tide you can already see how
far it's going out
it's gonna be a big tide today you guys
are working on repairing this gift a
bear bit it punched a bunch of holes in
it bears are like that they're always
breaking stuff well it's a beautiful day
and we got a lot planned so I better get
some breakfast going
we're wearing white them but not that
yes eat grow strong my son and we will
fight the octopus all right looks like
the Tide's dropped enough we're gonna go
out and Hunt giant Pacific octopus
[Music]
Flight of The Valkyrie yeah
here
all right octopus like to feed on
Crustaceans and clams and things like
that so they'll come in here in the
shallows and when the low tide goes down
they'll go into a little den and we're
trying to find those dens see if we
can't flush out an octopus
well baby eel right there
little isopod the pill bugs of the sea
little baby skull bin right there
another eel I'll put him back yeah
you got a little shrimp right there a
little tiny Herbie crab
this is the leaves of the bowl kelp
that's also edible
tastes a little bit like lettuce with a
pinch of salt
to see an enemy they call it a Christmas
henna because it's green and red
oh yeah now there's a sea cucumber
I think yes the early explorers called
these Gumboot chiting because they're
edible but they're so tough they said
you might as well be eating a Gumboot
that's a muscle that's a lie it's a live
one yeah this one we can actually eat
not a huge one but edible
a couple muscles there
I actually really like to eat mussels we
need a couple more of these we'll have a
good dish make sure they don't run away
okay I'm gonna put them right there
[Music]
it's a little starfish you want to hold
out your hand
there you go
oh here's two more SECU covers do you
want to eat those
no me neither
oh here's a little Titan is what they
look like underneath
look at this look at all these little
crabs in here
clam shells and debris around there yeah
there's a little bit of a cave down
under there
it goes way back there
feel anything it's hard to tell it sure
is a deep Den but I'm not sure anyone's
home
look at that there's a nice see here's a
good example of a Little Neck one
so that's a little net clam and that's a
butter clam Unfortunately The Season's
closed on these and so we can't take
them so we're just gonna do catch and
release in real silty areas we get a big
clam called a razor clam too those are
real fun to dig and eat
that's crazy I bet that makes good bait
swims like a leech
I look at all these holes right here
these little dimples
those are clams
but we're gonna put them back they're
not in Seasons you can see we get some
pretty big clams around here but the sea
otters go to town on them
is it a blood worm or a sand worm these
make excellent fish bait
all right check it out we got this
little Den here you see a little pile of
dirt and there's a crab shell where he's
been eating crabs clams
so we think he might be in there we'll
see got this little hose shove it in the
back there pour something like boiling
hot water or
something they don't like down in there
and that forces them out irritates them
yeah
oh come on out dude
I got him I got him look at that yes we
got him for around here this is actually
a smaller size we'll get them as they'll
fill a whole five gallon bucket
sometimes
okay oh he is Hefty I shouldn't set up
to the cabinet
okay
well that was awesome fun but the boys
are cold so we're gonna get them out and
get them warmed up in the cabin a little
bit
we're dipping the appetite
here first you can have a hot dog
[Music]
all right forever
it is
coaches for things no they don't know
what they're doing
all right there we go some spaghetti
carbonara
[Music]
just realized we haven't tasted our uh
kelp pickles you guys want to try some
kelp pickles sure sure okay we've got
two levels of spiciness
non-spicy here
it's not too spicy it starts burning
after a little bit but not bad it's not
quite crisp like a dill pickle no I
think it says I boiled it a bit too much
long probably oh that the Habanero's
down there this one is the habanero okay
I'm gonna try the death pickle real
quick oh
that's spicier
it's got a different flavor too yeah
yeah definitely actually it was it's
actually not too bad it's not too bad
but it's but it's definitely Zippy
share one
if I had a boiled all the liquid
together and just poured it over the
kelp instead of boiling it in the jar I
think it would be crunchier the spicy
ones are kind of good yeah I like that
there was a nice nice level of heat in
those it's time to clean some octopus
we're gonna have octopus for dinner
tonight
oh my Eagle's gonna take the children
you tenderize it is that how you go for
it so as you hit it it starts getting
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter and then
you keep going and then it relaxes eat
it okay I think the Eagles might even
don't take the children
oh here he comes here we go
oh there's another one chasing it down
too much
still suctioning even without its head
right away it's probably okay I think
it's time to cook some octopus
operate if you don't cook it right so
what I'm gonna do is bring it up to room
temperature dunk it in boiling water a
couple times to kind of gradually get it
up to Temp we're gonna boil it for a
little over one hour then we're gonna
pull it off let it cool down and then
cook it also I'm putting a little bit of
white vinegar in the water I'm boiling
it in that acidity will help break down
the meat a little bit
[Music]
one two three
one two three
three
all righty also I brought along some
bread pudding for dessert I'm gonna get
that started as well
got bread pudding in a little jar we're
just gonna boil this for a couple hours
it'll actually cook the bread pudding in
the jar keep it nice and warm for when
we're ready to eat it for dessert just
put the lids on nice and loose before
you put them on in the bath and they'll
cook inside the jar
foreign
[Music]
that's eight chairs
there we go guys you like it
on a scale of one to dead how much do
you hate the octopus
how are you do you guys like it um
try it you're just you're just enjoying
this alrighty let's get we got the bread
pudding here
there we go we got a bread pudding a
little bit of raisins a little chocolate
chips a touch of maple syrup
what does that mean can we open another
one
you gotta think do you like the red
booty yes yes
just gonna do some dishes clean up a
little bit take it easy
we're just getting a little campfire
going so the kids can roast some
marshmallows make some s'mores get them
hopped up on sugar before we try to get
them to bed you having fun yeah is this
been a good trip yes we're coming from I
actually don't think I've been
well buddy it's late I think we need to
get going to bed
yes yes yes
we got runner go
[Music]
on there you go you warm Bud well guys
it's late we gotta get up early tomorrow
so I'm gonna put up the camera I'll see
you in the morning
hey bud
looks like we got some muffins warming
up above the stove that's nice
all right Jake
yeah my pleasure hey thanks for having
me all right I'll see you later Charlie
not too often you get dropped off on the
tarmac to go catch your flight while
we're at the airport we're just checking
out Mark's airplane so yeah he's Alaskan
he's got his own airplane that's how
they roll it's such a good way to get
around and see the state you know and oh
yeah you got the car seat in there
that's nice it's just so uh
four-year-old can ride up front Mark
thanks for very much for one of the
hosting us and we had a great time oh
you're welcome it's been great it's been
awesome to have you guys here well we'll
see you again soon all right see if we
get the kids together go do something
awesome
okay
I am I'm sitting next to you put your
concerns anybody
yo Jake here you go
ah
right
well let's see guys I hope you enjoyed
this video if you want to see more
Adventures from the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel make sure to click subscribe we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning and check out our playlist I'll
put links in the video description below
thanks for watching if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]